so hello again here we are in Week three
already it's just amazing week 3 is
going to be very much a part of your
photographic exercise to say the least
it's all about lighting which of course
is what photography is all about ok so
for week 3 it's very straightforward
it's all about liking it's again very
rich in information remember watch the
videos which of course is essential and
at the end we're part of the assignment
is using your imagination and finding
new light sources for example I still
constantly looking for new ways of
lighting my photography actually I came
across this which is an incredibly
exciting piece of lighting equipment
it's very light the name of it is phlox
phl 0 X it's a little pricey but I
suggest that you take a look at their
website if you have a chance ok and
finally an encouragement to go to the
resources we have of really pretty in my
opinion very interesting interview with
Brian Hayes who is a writer but also a
very fine photographer and he and I had
a conversation about technical issues
which I think that will be very
beneficial to you it's mostly a podcast
so you could hear it sort of in the
background although i'd like you to pay
attention to what he has to say enjoy
week 3